الجزء الثاني من متابعتنا لمحاكمه ترامب
بيتعلق باللي صار بعد الجلسه واللي حيصير
عموما في المستقبل ترامب خلال الجلسه كان
ساكت ولا قال ولا كلمه الا وقت مجال نط
قلتي لكن بعد ما طلع من المحكمه ما وقفت
تصريحات اولها على باب المحكمه وهو خارج
لمن قال لانصاره كله تمام لا تقلقوا
وبعدها راح مع مجموعه من انصاره لاحد
مطاعم ميامي احتفل بعيد ميلاده 77 اللي
صادف امس وكمان وجه كلمه لهم من هناك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللي شفتوه كان الوضع داخل المطعم بس على
فكره مختلف كثير عن خارج المطعم كمان كان
في انصار ومتجمعين وبيهنوا بعيد ميلاده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد ما خلص الاحتفالات والاكل وكله راح
على النادي الجولف الخاص فيه وهناك عاد
كان الخطاب الرسمي الانصار واللي وصف فيه
اللي صار بانه اشنع واكثر شر صار في
امريكا او في تاريخ امريكا قانونيا
[موسيقى]
فكمان بهذا الكلام بالوسط بايدن بالرئيس
الفاسد وانه هاجم اكبر خصومه اساسيين طبعا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يعني
عظيمه ثانيه طيب خلينا نرجع لك محمد يعني
ايش فرص ترامب بانه يصير رئيس وهو متهم في
قضيه من هذا النوع او لو فرضنا مثلا تمت
ادانته فعلا هل ممكن يترشح هو مدان او
مسجون مثلا نتكلم قانونيا يعني
فيما يتعلق
بالاهم
الاجراءات المحاكمه هي مستمره هو بريء
في حال ادانته او في حال انه انحكم وانحبس
يعني هذا الموضوع
انشائك وفيه عده اراء قانونيه لانه
القوانين التي تمنع او تعطي هذا الحق
ما عمره صار عليها رئيس سابق للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واجه مثل هذه
الجرائم القانون الامريكي بالدستور
الامريكي لا يوجد اي منع على الترشز على
الترشح انما يوجد هناك ثلاث شروط اهمها ان
يكون عمر المترشح 35 سنه ان يكون اخذ
الجزيره
فما فوق نعم سته وان يكون اخذ الجنسيه
الامريكيه عن طريق الولاده وان يكون عاش
في امريكا لمده 14 14
سنه الان
هل يمنع ترامب بده في سيناريوهات قانونيه
اذا استمرت القضيه وترشح بعشرين اربعه
وعشرين تمكن من الفوز الان يمثل السلطه
التنفيذيه اللي هي دو يونايتد ستيت الخاص
في هذه القضيه وهو وهو جزء من الادعاء
العام وهو يعين رئيسه ويقيله فهو يملك
الصلاحيه انه
يخلي الادعاء العام يسقط هذا يسقط هذه
يسقط هذه القضيه في في حال تطورت القضيه
لانه يمكن ان يعني يمكن ان يمجل المشتكى
عليه بالسجن خلال مراحل القضيه ممكن
القاضي يامر بمرحله متقدمه انه يروح للسجن
صارت هذه الحاله في التاريخ الامريكي
وترشح احد الرؤساء الامريكيين وهو داخل
السجن لا يوجد ما يمنع ذلك ولكن لم يحالف
في الحظ بالفوز هلا اذا كان داخل السجن مع
انه هنالك موانع قانونيه كبيره تمنع اصلا
ذهاب اي رئيس الولايات
رئيس الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سابق الى
السجن في حال كان داخل وفي حال كان مدان
هو يملك الحق
انه يقدم اع على على اي شخص على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فهو قادر انه يعفي انه
يعفي نفسه
فبالمحصله قانونا لا يوجد يعني لو ترم في
كل الاحوال ودين او ما اودين كان داخل
القضيه او كانت لازالات القضيه ماشيه او
لسه ما هي ماشيه وفاز اموره تمام تمام
من دون ما نذهب لمحكمه تحدد هل يسمح
القانون لا يسمح لي انه هو عنده يكون لو
مخلينا نقول انه لا لسه ما كان فاز وانحكم
عليه انه يروح السجن انت بتقول في صعوبه
انه يدخل رئيس امريكي سابق السجن يعني انا
بوجهه نظري شبه مستحيل انه ينسجل رئيس
امريكي الى يوم واحد لانه في قانون اللي
بقفل الحق
الاشراف والحمايه
وهي الامن القومي تاع الرئيس السابق وما
بيقدروا هاي الجهات المعنيه الامنيه انها
تعطي هاي صلاحيات للسجن ويصير هم السجن
مكلفين في في هذه الحاله ممكن لانه ما
عمرها صارت هذا القضيه ممكن يكون توصل اذا
توصل لاعلى محكمه بامريكا
ممكن انها تحكم انه يعني نقدر هو ببيته
ولكن بغض النظر ايش عم بحكي هو في حال
فوزه ايش القانون بيحكي في حال الفوز عنده
قانونيه بتسمح له انه ما نخلي نوصل لمرحله
انا بقدر اكمل اصير رئيس او ما اكمل اصير
رئيس يعني مو معقول يعني احنا امامنا
محاكمه دراميه وامامنا بعدين كل الخيارات
اللي ممكن تمشي فيها القصه اكثر دراميه
كمان في هذا الموضوع على العموم نحن
بنشكرك على هذه التوضيحات كان معنا من
عمان المحامي المزاول في نيويورك محمد
تيسير النعيمي شكرا لك